chaque animation eric et ramzy
et ramzy nos deux comiques transgénique
josé ils sont là ce soir voilà beaucoup
des listes instant très con à féerique
très chaleureux
ok je sais juste pour voir dans quelle
humeur on était allé dans une bonne
humeur
mais c'est du judo gm alors en 2004 eric
et ramzy sont sous les feux de
l'actualité cinématographique c'est bien
dit ça un voile avait préparé on fait
quoi on est une réponse à ya pas de
réponse dans cet exemple savoir le 8
juillet il ya eu double zéro
pratiquement 2 millions d'entrées non
quelques minutes quasiment wii u qui dit
deux mesures dites 10 millions sur la
longueur bah oui en décembre il va y
avoir il étale tonnes
c'est génial à ces produits dont on est
le plus fier vraiment c'est le plus beau
film qu'on ait fait de notre vie
aujourd'hui vous êtes ici parce que vous
faites les voies d'un nouveau film
d'animation du studio dreamworks qui
s'appelle gang de requins qui sera en
salles le 13 octobre
alors eric judor vous vous doublez will
smith
bonsoir voila le mec de glace ou ballon
mais la voiture à los angeles
doublé par rapport à bodio caladons vous
doublez will smith et vous ramener
mais ce sont des vannes génial bras et
toi tu es lunettes
non c'est toi lui mais c'est toi qui
comprend les mains un peu tard jb déjà
vous doublez david foraine voilà
exactement la ville sereine qui est une
star aux etats unis n'en attend s'ils
savaient pas qui est david serait
apparemment ok mais lundi le mec il fait
le mieux les crabes ckac sinon tu vas
être obligé de faire le chat commence
pas à non ça fait longtemps on l'a
abandonné les délais le chat alors il ya
aussi ludivine sagnier virginie ledoyen
patrick timsit dany boon et aux usa y
avait robert de niro angelina jolie
martin scorsese enfin voilà quoi
yahia quoi que ce soit a compris ça
n'allait pas la valeur alors le pitch le
pitch quoi le pitch est aussi car oui un
petit poisson anodin oui il est plein de
charme
will smith quoi alors l'ue pourrait pas
son pitch donne à résister dit tout à
l'heure quand on regardait pas ce qu'on
regardait l'émission un peu en coulisses
et envoyé david charvet se disaient
qu'est ce qu'ils aient beaucoup de
sérieux
non mais si on avait été lui on serait
pas nous mais oui
pas vraiment marrer problème il prend
des râteaux même lui seul est largué
mail il avait panne sexuelle mais la
dame jeanne plaire des banh rien il
reste juste comme ça comme ça et ebay
tous ces 500 ban avant de ben ouais ce
soit quoi alors qu'elles soient vraies
choses
avec ce kit à
à wil vas-y mon chat fait parce que
sinon donc oscars un jeune poisson
anodin assiste accidentellement à la
mort d'un dangereux requins ils
profitent de la situation pour se faire
passer pour un grand chasseur de squales
mais le requin en question était le fils
était le fils du cher la trappe des
requins j'essaierai vous tenez le fils
du chef des requins gangster voile s'est
tiré d'une histoire vraie bien je suis
sur le banc de test déjà
non mais j'ai vu le film et je n'ai pas
aimé dont je préfère me taire car elle
est venue nous voir comme un bouffon
l'année derrière toi les gens qui
bossent et bien je suis allé faire
america relais toujours bah oui toujours
évidemment les américains feront d'état
américaine nasa ce propos le réalisateur
est un français
bergerot et on s'est tellement bien
entendu que on a un projet ensemble on a
travaillé
pardon je avec toi donc alors on va voir
à quoi ça ressemble vous allez alors là
je vais faire un truc c'est magnéto
serge voilà vous est ce que vous savez
le faire la dernière fois on a été
relooké tu le regardes regarder la
caméra alors le très bien les 90 ok
allez c'est parti la magnéto serge a
tourné dans son avance au non en chambre
qui croît de manière non 3 à 4 ou bac 4
2 à 4 à 3 à 3 à thonon 3 3 3 2 1 afin
qu'ils te magnéto serge oui
bienvenue